so i think the perspective that i'm able
to have
and the resilience uh and the thick skin
i mean i used to you know i was a high
school inner city school teacher
i you know gained fights i had to
separate i was a teacher during a school
shooting
um you know i have so many stories and i
think the resilience
that i learned and the thick skin that i
have it takes a lot to face me
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jay ventures
a community-driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance
opposed hillel at stanford leap and
birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders i'm really
honored to have with me today jillian
goldberg
vice president of marketing and investor
relations at guard knox cyber
technologies
a world-leading auto tech company and
the automotive industry's first cyber
tech tier
where she was also one of the first
employees originally from cincinnati
ohio
she completed her undergraduate work at
tulane university
before joining teach for america as an
inner city high school physics and
chemistry teacher
she is a mentor in the flagship program
through women in mobility
an expert at quantum hub accelerator
competitive power lifter and crossfitter
adviser to the alexander musk high
school in israel for entrepreneurship
among others jillian goldberg welcome to
20 minute leaders how are you
great how are you doing today i'm doing
fantastic thank you for joining me early
in the morning i really appreciate it
you have such a fascinating
journey er you know if i'm looking today
the traditional
traditional journey of somebody who's a
vice president of marketing and investor
relations at a cyber security company
gardnox i would never expect them to be
a high school science teacher and teach
for america
and and a bunch of other really
interesting things and so what i'd love
to
focus on in the beginning of our time
together is going a little bit through
your journey and
and i'd love to hear from you what what
really pushed you
as you were making decisions what to do
and and when
throughout your career and then get a
little bit into the role of vp marketing
as a at a cyber security company yeah of
course
so it's kind of funny um
my journey here because i don't think i
think even ten
five years ago if you would have told me
where i'd be today i would told you
you're crazy
um i grew up in cincinnati ohio which is
like
the epitome of kind of a middle america
i always tell people when you think of
your
average american small town um that's
how i grew up
um i was a huge soccer player so sports
defined and still defines my entire life
i would say
ah and i always really really wanted to
be
a doctor actually um
to yeah i was pre-med i actually got
into medical school
um and decided after working in
a the children's hospital in cincinnati
um every summer of my
college experience that it wasn't what i
wanted to do anymore
i think what i had thought i had fallen
in love with was just not
what it was i also think i was um
absolutely miserable taking pre-med you
know the medical system worked very
different in the united states so it was
four years of pre-med
and um organic chemistry i actually
loved it but i was like this is not
what this isn't what i want um
so i was very active in college with the
bone marrow drive and
i wasn't sure so i actually was
contacted by teach for america
um to apply so i said i don't know if
this is what i want
um for those of you don't know teach for
america is a division of americorps
um they take struggling low-income um
failing school districts essentially so
my
students have to meet a certain
threshold of what we call free and
reduced lunch so they have to live
um a certain threshold below the poverty
line
in the united states and we are brought
in for two years we do not have a formal
teaching background we actually
get that while we're teaching um and
we're brought in for two years and the
idea is
you know so we stay in education
the the motto of teach for america is
that one day
each and every student will have access
to an equal and equitable
education uh so
and so but but what you know at that
point in your life because
you know it's one thing being invited to
apply to something like this it's
another thing to actually go and do it
and then spend time doing it
where are you at in terms of your
thinking through your career you know
studying pre-med is not easy or you're
spending a lot of time in academia
what you know what what brings you even
you know intrinsically
to say you know what i'm gonna go for
this oh that's
i um i always used to say i wish i had
some like amazing thing to say like
i believe in this i had you know um
i've always been very attracted
attracted to education i've always been
very attracted to
the youth in general um
i do completely like buy into the fact
that education is the most powerful tool
with which to change the world um when
you want to gandhi's quotes and i think
that it's really
really uh i looked at the way i grew up
and i
am very blessed at the life my parents
gave me uh it's very interesting during
my first
training sessions at teach for america i
really had a guilt actually for the life
my parents gave me
um and the sacrifices my grandparents
obviously had made to give me that life
um because i didn't have the same kinds
of struggles that
a lot of my students and even fellow
teachers have i will say that there was
this um
you know an issue of a white savior
complex that we used to talk about a lot
um so you know i've been very blessed i
did
you know as a kid have a lot of medical
challenges
um and so i wanted to go into medicine
initially because i wanted to give back
what i was given and i realized i didn't
have to do that
through medi-medicine and actually what
i was
is you know my students i was in texas
so my students were
you know first generation um
[Music]
immigrants a lot of them would cross the
border and be in my class within 24
hours
and it was i thought one period a day i
actually taught in spanish
um so i i kind of was like
you know i am two generations removed
from y'all you know my students stories
you know my grandparents my great
parents grandparents came to the united
states
with a dream um like so many and
i kind of was sitting here and i said
you know your kids could have the life i
have
um so this is you know the value of hard
work and a dream i think
there's nothing there's nothing like it
and so you know
capturing just a little bit about of the
experience and working with these
with these children what what what what
did they teach you
you know that you're taking with you as
you're going on throughout your career
obviously today you're doing something
very very different
and you're deep into the tech ecosystem
here in israel but but
you know even in your day-to-day life
here what are you taking back from
from working for teach for america
wow so i actually think every skill i
have that has
led me to the professional i am today i
learn from teaching so
you know just from the very basic from a
marketing point of view taking a very
complicated
concept and really finding a way to make
it
you know to message it to my students to
break it down
to build a campaign for instance in
marketing is just like building a lesson
plan
um starting with the end in mind i think
time management prioritization um
stress like juggling 5 000 things at
once i mean
i it's so funny like the way that i run
everything here everyone laughs and they
say oh it's so obvious you were a
teacher
because of like the organization and the
way that i kind of juggle and
um i also think there's this
perspective that teaching gave me
that it doesn't matter really like we
get so caught up in our day-to-day lives
and how stressful work can be
but like this is not life and death
this is you know what i'm doing here in
tech it's amazing it's changing things
but
i don't go to bed at night wondering if
my students are going to have enough to
eat
or what's happening in the homeless
shelter like that's not a reality for me
anymore
um so i think the perspective that i'm
able to have
and the resilience uh and the thick skin
i mean i used to you know i was a high
school inner city school teacher
i you know gained fights i had to
separate i was a teacher during a school
shooting
um you know i have so many stories and
i think the resilience that i learned
and the thick skin that i have
it takes a lot to face me uh and i think
that really has been
huge you know like being an american in
the israeli text system
um it's this fake it till you make it
thing i used to do in teaching that i do
here it's like
uh you know i do it every day
i i love it and you know we we casually
even
skipped over the the the fact that you
competed in the ninja warrior
air competition in israel and so
obviously with crossfit
and you know athleticism literally a
warrior
but jillian take take me then to your
decision to enter the tech ecosystem
both deciding to go into you know
marketing but also cyber security it's
not it's not
trivial especially for somebody who's
not being who's not brought up in the
israeli ecosystem which is all about
cyber from the get-go
yeah so it's actually even not it's even
more of a nonlinear path
i came to israel i got my master's
degree at tel aviv university
um an emergency and disaster management
so i actually have a master's of public
health
um worked for israel worked with mata
um i was like this is what i'm gonna do
with my life
i thought this was how i was gonna
continue to give back i was very
interested in education
and you know some disaster zones and
what happens
uh and i went to one of my professors
and i said listen you know
can you help me network and he said i've
been working with you for a year
i know what you're capable of i'm
starting this company and you have to
come work with me
and i said like what are you talking
about this is not my path this isn't
what i want
i don't even want to make aliyah to
israel i'm just here for my education
um and so actually that's the ceo of
gardnock's moshe
and he gave me some of the best advice
i've ever been given and it's
that my background my resume my formal
education is a suitcase of skills
and i can take that suitcase with me
wherever i go
uh and i truly truly believe that so i
looked at guard knox
i looked at the market i looked at the
opportunity and i said this is a once in
a lifetime opportunity
i cannot give up and i truly believe
that i actually think not coming from
that background helped me
because i understood what my audience or
what my potential clients were thinking
um
what the mindset they're coming from i
have to teach myself this stuff
and it makes me a better teacher um and
it makes me a better marketer
and um you know i don't have the same
biases maybe that everyone else has
um i have to work harder
um maybe at times but it's not you know
it's about working smarter
not longer right um so really like
and now what is it about
you know translating something as as
deep tech as a cyber security which
you know and maybe non-trivial also to a
lot of potential customers that you want
to sell to
what did you learn about translating
that to you know
language that you know people would be
attracted to either would easily
understand or or would something would
be
even at least compelling to them
yeah so it's really interesting so
actually guard knox we do not define
ourselves anymore as a cyber security
company
okay um when i first joined we were um
automotive cyber security our team comes
from the israeli air force
um where they actually developed cyber
defense systems in our fighter jets and
missile defense systems
um so we first entered the market and we
said hey this is an amazing message from
defense aviation to automotive
the same technology approach let's bring
it to automotive
uh and we started working and that was a
very like
it was a very simplistic message that
people could really grasp and go oh yeah
um the regard for the israeli military
um is very you know big in most places
so that helped
but we quickly realized that our true
usp is so much bigger than just cyber
security cyber security's kind of that
foundation
which actually enables more levels of
connectivity so it got even
more technical we define ourselves as a
cyber tech tier supplier
we actually provide solutions and
technologies for the next generation
of electronic architecture of vehicles
as well as what's called
uh soa services oriented architecture um
i like to call it the smart phonization
of the automotive industry this idea
that we're you know we're a platform
that you can actually download apps um
and give yourselves a personalized
customized
experience in the vehicle um and so it
converts a driver to a subscriber of
services so while
cyber security is the foundation it's
actually so much more than that
so actually expanding that value
proposition
and being able to have the outsider
perspective and say hey guys
we're getting these questions um we're
doing so much more we're not just
cyber security and how do i message that
so
from a marketing perspective we went
through a process of um
you know building a new category uh
which i don't recommend anyone doing
during the pandemic it was very
challenging it was like
i think what april we did this of last
year like
i don't recommend it but we did it it
worked um and i think some of my
experience
um coming from outside the industry i
was able to kind of
see that maybe quicker than everyone
else was
wow and walk me through that that you're
building a new category phase in your
mind
what is sort of your guiding principles
as your as you're sitting there and
you're thinking wow we have to
reposition ourselves and it doesn't
sound very easy to me
no i think a lot of what what you have
to do is humble yourself
um and really kind of say let's go back
to the drawing board i think it's very
challenging for us to say i don't know
what i'm talking about i
don't know what we're doing um in the
terms of marketing and messaging and
we spend a lot of time with clients with
partners
asking questions and going how do you
you know you've been working with us how
are you seeing us what is our true value
add
to you you know we work with an amazing
marketing agency who came in and really
helped us with that penguin strategies
and um we also i mean i spent so much
time i will say the good thing about the
pan
the pandemic in the lockdown was i had
time to just think
and so much of you know we get in this
meeting craze and i didn't have time to
think so
i spent a lot of time with our ceo and
just thinking
um and coming up with this idea and it
originally came from a
pr perspective and we tested it with the
media a little bit first
and it caught on and so then we moved it
to the marketing side
okay very very cool i mean i think that
one one of the things that i'm always
curious about is you know
these different transitions and and
especially when somebody from outside of
the industry comes in and has their
unique perspective i think
it sounds really really really
interesting but what i'm really curious
about julian is
where does your actual passion lie so is
it is it is it in teaching in the is it
in
in rethinking content and being dynamic
in the world i mean if you look at
yourself
you know and and your future career as
well
who's jillian really
oh that's a great question i think you
know we ask ourselves that all the time
i really do think my passion you know i
obviously education
has a lot of my passion technology's my
passion but what that kind of boils down
to what that common denominator is
is the future and really how do we
leave um an impact and a change
um and so i think you know that's where
my passion lies is really
you know it seems so cliche but really
changing that i've been
really honored to kind of be a part of
the alexander mass high school in israel
um which is now just launched an
entrepreneurship program
so i got to merge my passion of
education with entrepreneurship
um and for the first time since i think
they said 1972
the jewish national fund has a way to
engage
students in israel that's not just
history and religion
um and i think specifically in today's
age how do we engage people in israel
that's not
um you know that is fit for the new age
right
you know not that those other things
aren't important but really how do we
connect with people
and that to me is where my you know my
passion is and my feet you know
i don't know where i'm gonna be um but i
know that like
who i'm gonna who i am so
think of what i love it and i'm going to
continue on this path
for you know the last few minutes that
we have and i want to take you back
again to childhood cincinnati ohio what
what really fascinates you
growing up so you mentioned that you're
you're big into sports
very curious you want to be a doctor but
you know middle school
what really gets you going inside
um so in middle school wow
um god i never want to think about those
years ago right but in middle school i
was very
very um my life was soccer i mean i
didn't know there was a life outside of
that but i would say
um medicine i was very driven by
medicine um
and being a soccer player and you know
we were
that was also kind of a part of it um
but i was always super improved by
medicine and
changing things and and everything like
that
um that was you know define my middle
school years for sure
and if you look today at your work or
where you're headed what what really
inspires you
on a day-to-day basis
um what inspires me is actually the
youth
um and that sounds kind of funny because
you know in working in mobility
but the idea that we're changing we're
changing things
for you know i don't have children yet
but we're changing things for my
children and our children in the next
generation
and this idea that we're actually
leaving um something better than what we
were given
and it's funny i was listening to the
news on the way to the office today
and it was just talking about these
record temperatures we're having in the
states
um right now and i was just thinking
like what are we doing
um to change this and i think that's
really what gets me up in the morning is
i actually feel at guard knox that i am
changing um the mobility industry and if
you think of the mobility industry it's
such a
fundamental industry um that is
you know moving us around the world um
to
so we really need to i feel like i'm
doing something to change that
and that's what gets me up in the
morning wow i love it
and what are three words that you would
use to describe yourself
um i like to describe myself as positive
i do think i'm an incredibly positive
human being
um i you know i'm very ambitious
and i'm incredibly driven um and i think
those things definitely come from
the sports background too positive
ambitious and driven jillian thank you
so much for sharing this time with me i
really appreciate it
i think that this non-linear career
pathway it's incredible and
and you know i'm inspired every time i
hear about you know people following
their heart and following their passion
and especially understanding the greater
picture of what they do and why they do
it
which i think is just very very big you
know in your life and in your journey so
thank you for sharing that with me
and best of luck with the rest of the
career and stay safe and stay healthy
thank you
thank you thank you michael